[Music]
We are back again with the next step for
our raycast car. This time we will make
our car move, organize the code to allow
for better customization, and fix a lot
of very specific
problems. Here's our car. First, let's
start by improving how we define the
wheels properties. Currently, all of our
wheels spring forces are defined in car
itself. But what if we want each wheel
to behave differently from each other?
So to do that, let's select one of the
raycast nodes and create a new script
and call it raycast wheel. We are going
to name this class raycast wheel and use
it to store all of the wheels properties
from now on. So just like in the car
script, create an export variable for
the spring strength, spring damping,
rest distance, and let's also give it a
variable name overextend if you wanted
to have that spring pulld down force.
Finally, we add our wheel
radius and create a ready bar for the
wheel mesh called wheel and set it to
get child zero. This will get the first
child of the raycast wheel and set it as
the wheel mesh. But you can do this in
any way you want as long as we get the
reference for the wheel mesh. Now that
we have our wheel class, let's drag in
the script and add it to the other
wheels.
Then select or cast wheels and let's set
the spring strength back to 5,000 and
the spring damping to 120. The other
values are fine as they are. Now let's
go to our car script and make some
changes to make autocomplete work. Let's
change the wheels array type to raycast
wheel. And now let's delete all of our
old variables. Now we couldn't make the
wheel class itself calculate the forces
by giving the wheel access to the car
rigid body. But I'm going to keep this
functions here in the car script itself
and use the wheel class only to hold
their properties. Now let's fix this
errors. Change the variable type to
raycast wheel so the autocomplete works.
And let's rename the suspension ray just
to ray to keep things small. You can
select the name and press Ctrl D to
multi select and change all the instance
at the same time. Then copy the array
dot and paste it before any wheel
variable to fix the errors.
And we are done. And here's a small tip.
If you are rendering the bug arrows, you
can divide the force by the mass to keep
the arrow size very consistent with the
movement. Everything should still work
the same. And let's not forget to remove
our hard-coded pull force and place our
new ray.extend here. And we can also
remove the get node line and replace it
by
ray.wheel. So let's make our car move.
We'll start simple. Let's add a new
export variable acceleration to our car
and set it to 600. And just like our
wheel suspensions, let's create a new
function named do single wheel
acceleration that receives a raycast
wheel named ray. To make it move, we'll
check if the wheel is colliding first.
Then we'll get the wheels forward
direction with minus ray.global
basis.z and the contact point with
ray.get collision point. Our vector
force is simply the forward direction
time the acceleration. And just like
before, we find the force position with
the global position we want to apply it
to minus the global position of the car
and call apply force passing the force
vector and the force position. If you
have a debug draw script, you can call
it here to draw the forces arrow. Then
we just need to call this function
inside the wheels
loop and something should
happen. Yeah, we are not quite there
yet. Anytime a wheel hit the ground, it
accelerates the car, which is not what
we want. We need to make sure only one
sets of wheels accelerates at a time.
You could simply check the wheels local
Z position here. A positive Z value here
would make it so only the rear wheels
move the car, but we can do better than
that. Let's add another export variable
to our wheels class and name it is motor
and set it to false.
Now, select the group of wheels you want
to accelerate and enable is motor for
them. I'm going to make this car
accelerate with the rear wheels because
I like how it feels, but most normal
cars usually accelerate with their front
wheels, so you might want to choose that
instead. And back to the car script.
Let's make sure ray do is motor is
true. Now, only the back wheels
accelerate. Next, we need to actually
control the car's acceleration. So, open
the project settings and go to the input
map tab and create a new action named
accelerate. Then find that action and
click on the plus button to add a key.
Press the W key and press okay. You can
add multiple keys for the action if you
want. Then do the same for the
decelerate action to break or reverse
the car using the S key.
Next, let's create a variable called
motor input and set it to zero and
create a unhandled input function. This
is a good function that will be called
for any input events that have not been
consumed yet. So here we'll be checking
if your accelerate action is pressed. If
it is, we set the motor input to one and
when it is released, we turn it back to
zero. And we also do the same to the
decelerate action, but we set the motor
input to minus one instead to make the
car move
backwards. And to use it, it is as
simple as checking if you have the motor
input and multiply your force vector
with
it. And there it is. We can accelerate
with a key
now, although maybe a bit too strong.
And because of how low the force is, it
can make the car flip very easily. One
of the reasons for that is that we are
applying the forces on the ground
contact point when we should have been
applying it at the center of the wheel
instead. So let's change the contact to
be raywheel global
position. Now our car has a much more
stable
acceleration and we should probably make
our suspension forces apply from the
center of the wheel as
well. To do that change the contact
variable after we are done with the
calculations and set it to rate
wheel.global of global
position. Everything is still working.
So, we are good. Now, one problem you
might see is that the car accelerates
too fast and the wheels lose contact
with the ground and that causes the
acceleration to flicker on and off. One
thing that contributes to this is that
the wheel apply forces toward the car or
the wheel front direction. And as the
car slightly changes rotation, so does
that force direction, which makes it
even worse. One technique to improve
that is to instead use a projected
force. You can cast a projected vector
with the rick cast normal and apply the
force along the floor instead. So here
the black projected force is applied
instead of the red one which might help
make the car stay more grounded. But for
this car at least it has barely any
difference. So we are sticking with the
normal one. But you can test them out
and see whichever you prefer. We can
always change to the projected force
later. So we can accelerate our car and
reverse it. But if we keep pressing the
key, the car will keep increasing its
velocity forever, which is not
good. So, let's give our car script a
max speed variable and set it to 20 m/s,
which is about 44 m. Now, inside the
acceleration function, let me fix this
typo here
first. We can get the forward velocity
of the car, we have forward
direction of the linear velocity. And if
our forward speed is higher than our max
speed, we can just return and not
accelerate the wheel. And while this
works while the car starts and stops its
engine when reaching the max
speed. So a better way to do that is to
decrease the acceleration force just so
we can win over the drag and keep the
velocity more
stable. But before we add drag and
improve the acceleration, let's quickly
make our wheels move. To rotate the
wheels is very simple.
We just need to call raywheel rotate x
and rotate it by minus the velocity time
delta time. And to calculate how fast
the wheel should turn, it is also very
easy. The wheel surface area is 2pr. So
we multiply it by 2 pi and the wheel
radius. This will make sure the wheels
rotate exactly as it needs. But you can
also clamp this value to make the wheels
rotate better at high speeds. Now you
might have noticed, but our car won't
ever stop by itself. It is actually
losing speed, but that's because Goto
uses a default linear dump of 0.1 that
reduces all movements over time. If we
remove that, the car won't ever stop
again and we'll keep going
forever. So, let's create a new
deceleration variable of 200 that will
stop our car. We are going to remove the
motor
input and use it in an if before the
apply force instead.
Then we are going to add our drag force
to be the global basis.z the car's back
direction times the deceleration times
sinf velocity. This will return one if
the velocity is positive or minus one
otherwise making sure we always add the
force opposed to the movement of the
car. Now our car will quickly
stop. Another thing we can do is only
add this deceleration force when it is
not using the
motor. so that our acceleration force
does not have to compete with it. And to
remove the drag flicking back and forth,
we can check if the car has some speed
in either direction with ABS
velocity. Now that we have the basics
done, let's improve how our car
accelerates. Right now, it has a
constant acceleration, which is very
unrealistic. Acceleration in real cars
is not constant, and it changes in time
based on the speed and torque of the
motor due to how the transmission work.
And we can make a simplified version of
that with
curves. So let's create a new export
variable named acceleration
curve of the type
curve. Done that. Let's create a new
curve on the right. And just so we have
more space, you can right click the
node, go to super resource, and select
that curve. This will select the curve
and display it alone in the inspector.
Then you can click on the three dots and
make it a floating window and resize it
to a bigger size.
Now we got some space to work with. So
this will be our car acceleration curve.
The horizontal line is how much speed
the car has and the vertical one is how
much acceleration it will give the car.
So this script will tell the script how
much of the acceleration it will give
based on the car's current speed. So
let's activate snap and place some
values. The car will start with 30% of
its
acceleration and it will keep increasing
it until it hits about 30% of its total
speed. Then it will slowly decrease
until it hits 80% of the max speed. And
finally have a sharp decrease until it
hits 10% when it reaches its max speed.
Since code form curves can now use
values outside of zero and one. So you
could use real velocity values here
instead of percent of the max velocity
we are using here. Now we can close the
window and the inspector tab will return
to its duck
position. Back to our code. Let's get
the speed ratio of our cart by
calculating the current velocity divided
by the max
velocity and get our real acceleration
from the curve by calling sample baked
and passing the speed ratio the
horizontal value of the curve and we'll
use that to multiply the final force.
Now let's set acceleration to 150 so we
can see it
working. The car will now slowly
accelerate until it picks up some speed
and then barely stop when it hits its
max speed. Now that we got our car
moving, let's take a look at some
problems and fix them. Let's increase
the acceleration and the max speed and
try running the game again. And our car
is sinking. The higher the speed of the
car, the more things get strange. And
this shouldn't be happening. The
strangest thing about this is that when
we run physics in slow motion,
everything's great. But it all breaks
when we get back to realtime speeds. So
to explore what's going on, let's draw a
sphere where the raycast hits the
ground. And now we can clearly see
what's wrong. The raycast is lagging
behind. The faster we are, the worse off
its position is. So I'm not sure if this
is a bug or not. But if we select the
recast and go to its documentation, it
says it calculates the recast each
physics frame and holds the results
until the next one. But I think it's
getting the hit position from the
previous frame and messing up our
calculations. To fix this, we are going
to manually update the raycast
ourselves. First, select the raycast
nodes and disable them by unchecking the
enable property. And inside our wheel
loop, we just need to call wheelforce
recast update to manually update recast
collision. And just like that, now our
physics works and the car is no longer
sinking. And this also helped fix jumps.
If you try using ramps before this, the
lagging rate cast was making the car
flip every time by making the spring
apply forces at the wrong time. You can
also remove this if statement because
the acceleration curve now does this for
us. Another thing we can do is make all
four wheels slow down the car, not only
the ones that have motors. We can do
that by putting the is motor and motor
input checks inside and moving some
variables around. And on the else
statement, you can check for not motor
input. If you want to keep the drag
working only when not pressing the
accelerate button like before, we just
need to rename your force to drag tors
vector and use that
instead. And now all of the four wheels
will affect the car to stop
it. You can adjust the absolute velocity
check to remove the flickering drag as
needed. Lastly, let's try to change the
wheels a bit. We'll make the back wheels
bigger. Select both of the back wheels
mesh and increase their scale to
1.35. You can use the measure tool to
figure its approximate
radius which seems to be about 0.5. So
let's select both
wheels and change the radius to
0.5. But now something strange is
happening. The car is moving by itself
before the drag starts and stop it.
The reason for that is that the car is
slightly tilted. So the spring has a
little bit of forward force. Also, the
correct wheel radius for this should be
0.54. To fix this problem, let's go back
to the spring calculation code. Instead
of applying the force in the spring up
direction, we are going to use the
collision point normal direction
instead. This will make sure our spring
forces won't move the car. And now our
car stays firmly on the ground. There is
a slightly more complicated way to deal
with this, but using the rake as normal
works just fine for most
cases. And just to finish it off, if you
want to prevent your car from flipping
over, there is a very neat little trick
a lot of arcade games uses, which is to
change the center of mass to be below
the car when it leaves the ground. This
will make the car really want to stay
upright, making it very hard to flip.
So to do that, let's create a ground
variable and check if any of the wheels
are touching the ground. If they are, we
set the center of mass to zero. But if
they are not touching any ground, we
make sure center of mass mode is set to
custom and put the center of mass below
the car. You can play with these values
until you find something that is not
hard to flip and not too
crazy. And now the car will try really
hard to reorient itself when
landing. But that's it. Our car is
finally moving and we solved a lot of
issues that we found. Now all that's
left for the basics is to make it turn
and add some real friction to the
wheels. As always, if you want to
support me, you can get the files using
these tutorials on Patreon. I hope you
like this video and until next time.